the road up to mount algor the northern
Iraq is dangerous
these are Iranian Kurdish Fighters known
as komala who have been battling Iran's
government
[Music]
here they get out and attacking
instructions
their last drills were conducted a few
kilometers away from Iran's Army
positions
before they pulled out in response to
recent security agreement between Iran
and Iraq
the commander is amdad banahi who's one
of Iran's Most Wanted men he says two of
his brothers were executed for
affiliation with the Kurdish armored
group Iran has set September 19th a
deadline for them to lay down their
weapons
we will not lay down our weapons we are
temporarily repositioning away from the
border we do not want war but since Iran
declared war against us in 1979 we have
had to take up arms to defend ourselves
and our people
among seven anti-iran groups which have
been operating in Iraqi semi-autonomous
Kurdish region for nearly 40 years there
are concerns as to why the Kurdish
Regional government allows these
Fighters and their camps in its
territory while it insists it's looking
for a peaceful solution
Iran has repeatedly bombed the fighters
locations
saying those sites were being used to
launch attacks against it
these Fighters say they want Iran to
become a secular multi-ethnic country
that guarantees the rights of both Kurds
and Iranians equally but Iran accuses
them of being separatists seeking to
undermine National unity and fueling
last year's Mass demonstrations
it's been one year since the death of
Masa amini a young Iranian Kurdish woman
who died in police custody and sparked a
nationwide unrest
we've supported the demonstrations
politically and that's our legitimate
right but Iranian security forces have
killed many of our people and put many
others in jail for allegedly fermenting
violence but on top of that Iran accused
them of being manipulated by Israel
to carry out attacks inside Iran
including assassinations and those that
Target its nuclear facilities
Israel is certainly backing these groups
with training and Advanced Equipment
which they used against our military and
sensitive facilities this has been also
admitted by their operatives who have
sent and directed by Israel to incite
Armed Insurgency sabotage of State
facilities and to murder our security
individuals we captured them even during
last year's demonstrations and we have
clear evidence
many of these Fighters claimed they've
LED from Iran walking and hiding from
the Iranian Army for days before joining
these training camps
Iraqi officials with the central
government in baghdadi insist their
lands cannot be used to launch attacks
against their neighbors
our Border guard forces have been
deployed in coordination with the
regional Kurdish Administration to
prevent infiltration and attacks inside
Iran a security committee has been
formed to relocate their camps away from
the border the Iranian Kurdish Fighters
say they're abandoning their locations
in order not to give Iran a reason to
launch more attacks inside Iraq but not
their weapons which they believe are the
only guarantor for their safety and that
could put Iraqi officials both in
Baghdad and in the northern Kurdish
region at odds with Iran
near Iraq's border with Iran
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera